thanks to us yes yes we are we I think
we ran our world champion here in
Bucharest ding welcome back to the
studio congratulations on finishing this
tournament with an important victory
yeah thank you tell us a bit about
today's game did you expect Bogdan to
come out swinging like he did Sweeney
like with a sharp sword aggressive
Robert told me that he sometimes will
press the clock very hard okay but today
he no it doesn't it didn't happen and
but he came out very aggressive yeah
reversy with his opening
and he played this D5 Pawn sacrifice
very popular
maybe 10 years ago yeah
yeah
it will also move English played against
the Magnus in where kanzi
and here let's play D6 you're 27 and
he got himself in some trouble in that
game he actually lost that game yes but
you had some improvements I remember
it's a old line Old Main Line yeah but
G6 is
and no way yeah
also there are many games with this guy
here I try to remember my preparations
before
yeah Queen C7 I think it's a move
if rookie 8 seems to be the bad the
second most played move in the position
yeah if Knight C3 97 it also possible
Bishop H6
quiz
c796395 here you might have Knight D5
yes take tank
now it seems like he has very strong
initiative yeah for uh for the pawn
but he didn't do that
after Queen to C7
[Music]
he played the move Bishop to H6
yes I do
is if nice things right here I can't
think on E5 my remote is placed on f8
and it protects the Palm episode there's
no Queen takes F7 very nice yeah so he
wanted that but with Bishop to H6 first
right so he had to play Bishop H6 first
and now I can go Knight F5 yeah this has
more details that's a nice intermediary
remove very cool and we were kind of
discussing this position we didn't know
where to put the queen going to G4
but I have F5 I guess
yeah F5 was one of the moves Rook d8 is
also a great box 1935 I also consider
take the Rook
yeah
and that's probably the most precise
if it takes
with a queen with a bishop oh yeah
yeah you played a really precise game in
in this one and uh when did you feel at
what point did you feel like you're
taking over the initiative you're
gaining the advantage in this game
actually I didn't like group D1 I
thought he would take on G7 play Rook D1
here I have to go D6 yeah yeah it takes
I take a bishop Queen to D3 or D2 Bishop
E7
on group D7 yes
a queen C6 oh the movements
that's better
but this is such a difficult move to
make yeah putting the queen on the same
diagonal as the bishop Maybe 95.
yeah this is not easy though
Queen E6
especially from afar it looks scary yeah
it looks great scary also
I will consider and take
take and Bishop and fix Maybe
black also better by rookie too
and because he Bishop if Bishop can put
on defaults and he's better but yeah
you're putting the bishop first on D4 if
he moves the Knight very nice and he
didn't go for this he went for for okay
D1
and now he started you know pushing the
H Pawn trying to open up the position
trying to get to your king but you had a
lot of pieces next to your kingdom
there's a lot of knights
actually belongs to H6 yeah and but
somehow here there's
if if he goes H6 yeah I have the dark
Square bishop and he didn't come control
my dark Square over my king size yeah
yeah so it's there's no way you would
love to play Queen F6 the problem is you
cannot fly the Knight and Bishop then it
will be very strong but
are not so many pieces here yeah
so I'm not worried and at this point
after Queen to D7 I think this was a
very precise move by you as well he
started you know
showing that he's not feeling
comfortable with the position he was
like shaking his head he he felt like
he's in deep trouble at this point yeah
and um
quite interesting I remember I forgot if
you take or which move here
he drops the park oh he he dropped the
pawn at some point oh yes it takes but
he
maybe two hearts
fell yes yeah yeah very very unfortunate
difficult position anyway at this point
and I think he converted with great
Precision ding congratulations uh for
the last round sure the event didn't go
your way what is next for you right now
let's have to go back to
to rest some for some time get some rest
do you know what your next tournament is
or you don't have that mapped out yet
for now it's a global Chase League yeah
in Dubai in Dubai yes yes well we'll see
you there for sure so thanks for joining
us thanks for playing here in Bucharest
I hope you enjoyed it and we'll see you
soon thank you thank you guys thank you
Christian